bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 5 janvier
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale accompagnés de nos
invités mais également des journalistes
de la rédaction
on commence au but avec les titres de
cette édition les salariés du centre
hospitalier andré mignot du chesnay en
colère ils manifestent pour dénoncer ce
qu'ils estiment être des suppressions de
postes et une dégradation de leurs
conditions de travail
les soldes d'hiver se prépare dans les
magasins l'heure est aux derniers
rangement avant le jour j
un rendez vous des plus importants pour
les commerçants après une fin d'année
morose et enfin évident information
jeunesse le centre départemental des
ménages
l'association kids versailles pour
montigny le bretonneux retour sur les
raisons du changement et sur les
nouvelles missions avec pierre yves
stucki son directeur et enfin le 1er
janvier la traditionnelle promotion
civile la légion a été annoncée cette
année 616 personnes sont décorées par
l'hiver est là jacquelot lloze maire de
magny les hameaux de 1983 à 1989 puis de
1995 à 2012 il est élevé au grade de
chevalier la légion récompense ses
cinquante cinq années de service on
l'écoutait au micro de mélanie côté
c'est donc lié au ministère de
l'intérieur
c'est quelque chose qui me touche
notamment par rapport à la durée parce
que c'est quand même donc
le ministère l'intérieur par rapport au
vu donc de mon dossier
ces 55 ans de ma vie effectivement par
rapport à ce que j'ai c'était donc à 18
ans que je me suis engagé déjà donc pour
mon pays en quelques sortes et pourront
que les français tout simplement pour
moi c'est une reconnaissance plus qu'une
fierté et en même temps donc c'est
l'accomplissement d'un travail collectif
avec les habitants avec les élus à
différents moments donc de ma carrière
politique tout simplement
et lors de sa cérémonie de voeux le
maire a donné le ton pour le prochain
conseil communautaire de saint quentin
en yvelines samedi la nouvelle
agglomération de 12 communes se réunira
pour la première fois la majorité de
droite renforcera mathématiquement ses
rangs avec l'arrivée des élus de cinq
communes
mais pour bertrand au lion l'opposition
aurait dû avoir une place plus
importante
elle n'aura vraisemblablement aucune
vice président sékou téloche aujourd'hui
on n'a plus voix au chapitre
tout simplement si par exemple dans
l'intérêt communautaire mais la majorité
de l'agglomération des sites qu'il y
aura les piscines et bains on financera
d'après ce que j'ai lu dans la presse 10
millions d'euros pour une piscine à
maurepas qui a aucun esprit
communautaire voilà il faut pas se
servir de l'agglomération comme d'un
objet partisans parce que c'est une
coopération entre les communes et la
base de tout ça c'est les communes qui
mettent en commun
malgré toute leur diversité qui mettent
en commun leurs finances dans un projet
de territoire élargi au service des
habitants en premier lieu dans toute
leur diversité politique toujours
l'information est désormais officielle
benoît hamon ne siégera plus au conseil
municipal de trappes il aura donc
également absent de la nouvelle
agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines élu en mars 2014 sur la liste
du maire sortant guy malandain l'ancien
ministre par ailleurs député de la 11e
circonscription venait de mener campagne
lors des régionales aux côtés de claude
bartelone élus en ile de france en
décembre il était aujourd'hui dans
l'obligation de faire un choix en raison
de la loi sur le non-cumul des mandats
il a donc choisi de démissionner de son
poste à la ville de trappes
on les écoute à chaque fois que ce genre
de décision à ce sujet à des
interprétations jaurès député la
réception conception et comme
aujourd'hui en sur la question on attend
la décision de la région que cela
quelques financement des associations on
attend des décisions importantes que sur
la question du financement du
commissariat d'elancourt on attend d'ici
là par contre il me semble que je ne
serai pas inutile à la commission
permanente de la région on a quelqu'un
d'aussi membres pour faire en sorte que
tous les investissements de la région ne
soit fléché seulement vers des communes
a mis un pécresse
après c'est toujours un peu un crève
coeur que de la chine un vendeur et et
on est candidat aux régionales alors que
j'avais démissionné tourette conseil
municipal de trappes
je savais que j'allais devoir à nouveau
refaire ce choix et comment réagissaient
les habitants de trappes à cette
nouvelle nous sommes allés leur poser la
question aux gens pensent à rien il est
c'est un homme libre il peut faire ce
qu'il veut moi vous savez trappe
continuera de vivre sans lui
elle va le regretter mais j'espère un
autre qui va remplacer ce sera mieux
o comme lui pâques c'est dommage c'était
c'était une bonne personne en plus on
l'aimé bien on ne discute et bien avec
lui comme maram jamais rendu service
il peut partir et comme quand on croise
au marché il a du mal à répondre bonjour
à ses concitoyens je le regretterai pas
vous dire que c'est une personne qui a
beaucoup de sueur sur la ville de
trappes
c'est une personne aussi pour un jeu je
m'attendais pas son départ aussi c'est
malheureux j'ai précisé benoît hamon
reste député de la 11e circonscription
social à présent ce matin au centre
hospitalier andré mignot du chesnay les
salariés ont manifesté leur colère
contre la direction en débrayant une
heure pendant qu'un comité technique
d'établissement se réunissait une
centaine de personnes se sont
rassemblées sous les drapeaux de
syndicats sud et cgt pour dénoncer la
suppression de 25 postes dans les
semaines à venir
un reportage signé william el est
patrick jacquet dixmude aujourd'hui on
commence par les allées sache demain ça
sera les supporters les apc qu'un vent
de colère qui soufflait ce matin dans
les couloirs de l'hôpital andré mignot
du chesnay
ces syndicats sud et cgt rejoints par
une centaine de salariés ont dénoncé une
récente déclaration de la direction
selon l'hôpital voudrait réaliser des
économies aux dépens des salariés en
réorganisant les services ces 25 à
janvier enfin 25 cdd qui ne vont pas
être renouvelé donc il ya eu 25
suppressions de postes cette mise en
place fait suite finalement aux déficits
cumulés de sur plusieurs années due
principalement aux travaux des grades
d'agrandissement de l'établissement
et aujourd'hui on se payait le personnel
alors qu'il n'y est pour rien qu à cette
suppression de 25 postes d'agent de
service hospitalier n'est qu'une
première étape et pour sébastien points
cela aura forcément des répercussions
sur la charge de travail des aides
soignantes
évidemment c'est une perte de revenus
pour certaines catégories les plus
précaires et puis surtout effectivement
aujourd'hui avec la mise en place de ce
poule c les agents vont aller à droite à
gauche sans connaître les patients sont
connaître la spécificité du service où
il ya des normes d'hygiène dans certains
secteurs qui sont très strictes et
aujourd'hui on n'aura plus à on perd 7,7
commencé de qualité ceux de cette
connaissance
la direction de l'hôpital a annoncé dans
un communiqué que ce plan pluriannuel de
retour à l'équilibré budgétaire est la
conséquence des mesures d'économies
visant résorber le déficit de
l'assurance maladie les mesures de
réorganisation de l'activité de
nettoyage seront progressivement
centralisée au cours de l'année 2016 est
assurée par une seule et même équipe la
réduction des postes affectés à ces
activités sera géré par des
réaffectations en interne promotion
professionnelle et des départs naturels
et revenons à présent sur le réveillon
le 31 décembre l'occasion de se
retrouver pour la dernière fois de
l'année autour d'un bon repas c'était
peut-être votre programme
mais certains se trouvent isolés et
notamment les personnes âgées selon une
étude de 2014 réalisée par la fondation
de france
une personne âgée sur quatre est seul
pour y remédier le temps d'un après midi
la fédération des yvelines du secours
populaire invités 80 iv noah a partagé
un repas de fête à bord d'une fait d'une
péniche pardon ce reportage est signée
mélanie potier mairie loisel et camille
lambert
c'est au pied de la grande dame de fer
que leurs croisières a débuté ses 80
personnes âgées et isolées sont les
invités du secours populaire des
yvelines c'est la troisième édition de
cette initiative solidaire
il ya trois quatre ans cela dit quand
même que l'on pensait souvent aux
enfants pour noël on pense à aux
familles aussi parce qu'on fait les
libre-service ne
elle pour que les gens puissent fêter
noël à la maison etc et que bague l'aube
allemand nous on oubliait souvent un
petit peu les plus anciens et que
quelque part ce n'est pas tout à fait
juste donc on essaye de faire en sorte
de penser à nos anciens parce que je
pense qu'il le mérite bien discuter
déguster un bon repas et pour beaucoup
découvrir paris c'était le programme de
cette croisière qui duré un peu plus de
deux heures parce que je viens ici je
dirais g
regarde tout parce que c'est la première
fois que je viens ici à côté 29 il parce
que j'ai pas vu l'affairé fait et c'est
bon tout est fait de thébaux j'ai déjà
mis madame d'un résident sur moi et ils
présentent qu'un singe l'école des ponts
et nous sommes tous des humains et lui
devons tous nous aimer parce que c'est
la femme de l'année 2015
on a intérêt pour reprendre une nouvelle
année 2016 avec beaucoup de pays mais
internet et musique chant petit pas de
danse et l'estomac bien rempli
c'est yvelinois n'avait plus qu'à se
laisser porter et comme chaque année à
la même période les soldes d'hiver
prennent leurs quartiers dans toutes les
enseignes elles débuteront demain
mercredi 6 janvier pour six semaines
un rendez vous qui se doit d'être
rigoureusement préparé par les boutiques
ils représentent en moyenne 15 % de
chiffre d'affaires annuel regardez ce
reportage réalisé par sephora namani
fanny bourdon et six molière
demain mercredi 6 janvier démarre les
soldes d'hiver pour six semaines
un rendez vous attendu par tous les
amateurs de bons plans qui commencent
leur repérage même si la multiplication
des ventes privées et promotions sur
internet diminue l'attrait de ces seules
deux officiels - autrement
j'attendrai semaine prochaine en
principe on fait toujours un petit tour
avant et après on après en profitent des
avantages de le descendre un petit un
petit tour pour repérer un c'est les
soldes toute l'année toute façon si on
va sur internet on peut se promener
avoir toujours du low cost donc c'est
pas la démarche
ce rendez vous représente pour les
boutiques l'un des trois pics économique
de l'année avec juillet et décembre
les enseignes réaliste à ce moment-là 15
à 30% de leur chiffre d'affaires annuel
donc là cette année on a mis les sols de
devant en entrée de magasin
tout de suite on démarre avec du moins
50 ensuite du moins car en ou 1 30 et
d'une oie vent est au fond du magasin
les produits qui sont non des côtés et
la nouvelle collection qui va arriver là
on espère qu'avec le froid qui revient
un nouveau conte puissent écouler tout
le stock de culte qu'on n'a pas pu
écouler parce que le début de l'automne
au fin de l'automne en tout cas été très
très doux la réussite des soldes est
directement impactée par la météo du
moment et le contexte social la première
journée est souvent un bon indicateur
dans cette enseigne comme pour ses
confrères du centre commercial la moitié
du chiffre d'affaires du premier jour
devrait être réalisée à 16 heures en
attendant ce soir tous les articles
devront être étiquetés pour que tout
soit prêt demain et leur mission cdd
d'orienter les jeunes vivent une
information jeunesse le centre
départemental d'information pour les
jeunes déménage et s'installe à montigny
le bretonneux
pour nous en parler ce soir pierre yves
stucki président divine information
jeunesse bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation donc vos locaux ont
déménagé vous avez déménagé vous est
maintenant installée à montigny le
bretonneux qu'elle soit un petit peu les
raisons de ce déménagement
sa voix qu'on quitte pas aussi
facilement une ville comme versailles on
était installé depuis 40 ans plus de 40
ans et 25 ans à la même adresse et vous
n'avez une vraie notoriété
en fait si on est parti c'est vraiment
pour des raisons très pratiques c'est à
dire qu'on avait une très belle surface
mais qui était un peu trop grande par
rapport à l'activité notamment d'accueil
du public qui est un peu en train de
diminuer au profit d'autres formes
d'action
et donc ça nous coûtait cher ça nous
coûtait cher dans un contexte de baisses
de dotations puisque nous sommes
financés par le département l'état et
puis union européenne est donc très
concrètement c'est glee soit en reste là
et on finance des beaux locaux et on
pourra plus financer du personnel les
informateurs jeunesse pour aider les
jeunes soit on privilégie le personnel
et les services aux jeunes et on trouve
des locaux qui sont plus adaptés et
c'est évidemment ce deuxième choix qu'on
a fait donc il a fallu chercher où aller
on départ on pensait plutôt sur
versailles puisqu'on avait cette
notoriété
voilà on n'a pas trouvé d'autre part la
ville de versailles elle a fait d'autres
choix pour sa politique jeunesse et ne
souhaitait pas soutenir financièrement
il régit ce qui ne simplifie pas la
tâche
et donc comme on anime ce réseau
d'information jeunesse à travers le
département
on avait des bons contacts avec
différents points et bureau information
jeunesse dont celui de montigny et donc
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait une
vraie opportunité pour revenir sur un
territoire où il ya beaucoup de jeunes
il a une densité urbaine et puis un
bassin de vie étudiante qui permettait
de certes de quitter un territoire on
était connu mais d'en rejoindre a un qui
est dynamique et il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de jeunes qui sont le public
auquel on s'adresse
la proximité avec la faculté va changer
quelque chose à la mettre d'autres
actions pas justement à cause de ces
jeunes qui sont très près maintenant du
coup oui tout à fait si on viendra c'est
effectivement on souhaite pouvoir
travailler étroitement avec tous les
acteurs de la jeunesse sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
on garde notre activité d'animation du
réseau au niveau du département ça c'est
important de le dire en garde notre
activité de centres d'information
européen mais on a aussi une activité
localement d'autant que ce qu'on voit
c'est que depuis quarante ans que qui
existent ces structures d'information
jeunesse
beaucoup de choses ont changé notamment
dans les modalités d'accès d'accès à
l'information je pense que si on va au
centre commercial à côté et qu'on
demande à un jeune quel est son premier
réflexe quand ils cherchent une info je
doute qu'ils nous disent que son premier
réflexe est d'aller dans un local à lui
ouvrir des classeurs je pense qu'il sort
son smartphone de sa poche et il fait
une recherche
on voit bien que le premier réflexe
d'accès à l'information est différent
aujourd'hui
ce qui explique qu'ils moins de visites
spontanées dans un premier temps et
qu'on doit se déployer sur d'autres
formes donc on va beaucoup développé
notre site internet comme on a déjà 145
mille visites chaque année ce qui en
fait le premier point de contact
beaucoup plus que les dix mille jeunes
qui poussent la porte de nos locaux
chaque année et mais on va aussi
développer on a commencé à faire les
actions hors les murs dans les
établissements scolaires à l'université
j'espère qu'on pourra aussi avoir des
bonnes relations
vous parlez vous aviez vous dit le fait
de changer de locaux stimulation de
subventions en 2013 donc l'association
avait failli fermer justement à cause
des baisses de subventions aujourd'hui
vous en êtes où est ce que c'est que
toujours elles mêmes difficultés que
vous rencontrez est ce que vous allez
trouver des solutions alors la
difficulté avec connu l'association
n'était pas seulement et peut-être même
pas d'abord une question de manque de
financement c'était un déficit de
gouvernance mondiale et plus de bureaux
pour l'association ce qui évidemment est
assez problématique
à cette époque là et je pense qu'on peut
lui rendre hommage et dire que la ville
de versailles a aussi su soutenir à
l'époque c'était françois xavier bellamy
qui était adjoint au maire de versailles
inquiète adjoint au maire de versailles
toujours qui avait assuré une présidence
at-il d'intérim et je lui ai succédé en
revanche ce qui est vrai c'est que par
ailleurs le financement diminue parce
que on connaît le contexte voilà est le
département qui est notre premier
financeur lui même voit sa dotation
baisser donc il peut pas faire de
miracle et ça je le conteste pas très
concrètement c'est une baisse de 40
mille euros par an pendant trois ans les
solutions vous mettez en place mais le
fait de quitter déjà une première
solution importante
il ya aussi une action pour conserver
les autres subventions qu'on a notamment
en assurant bien notre mission le centre
d'information européen ce qui nous
permet de continuer à voir la subvention
européenne et donc en redéployant un peu
l'effectif avec un peu moins de
personnel sur les tâches administratives
comptables et beaucoup plus sur les
aspects opérationnels l'émission ont
changé depuis la création l'installation
d'associations de cars 1974 à versailles
alors ça dépend si on pense aux
finalités ou aux modalités de
réalisation je pense que les finalités
n'ont pas changé l'idée c'est toujours
que les jeunes ont besoin
d'accompagnement d'être pour intégrer
dans un monde qui est pas facile d'être
encore plus dure contre x en revanche
les modalités elles ont complètement
changé l'exemple de la formation au sens
propre puisque c'est la mission première
du réseau d'information jeunesse
elles ont changé le
le réflexe premier qui est d'aller dans
un local pour consulter la documentation
ça c'est quelque chose qui diminue
fortement et on le voit au niveau d'une
information jeunesse mais toutes les
animations de réseau le montre donc les
modalités changent le service en ligne
augmente
et puis nous développons aussi nos
davantage et services autour de l'aide
ou au job
donc on vraiment ce créneau spécifique
des jobs d'été qui sont très importants
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils permettent aux
jeunes d'avoir une première expérience
avant de prétendre à deux expériences
finalement aujourd'hui les entreprises
veulent bien embaucher des débutants
avec expérience ce qui peu paradoxal et
ses jobs sont un élément de réponse
l'aide au logement qui est un vrai
problème sur le département aussi enfin
une dernière question avant de nous
quitter ce que vous avez des actualités
des choses que vous allez mettre en
place pour 2016 alors le dans les choses
qui sont importantes que le premier
c'est qu'on va très concrètement dans
les yeux ce que je viens de dire
développer et changer notre site web
il ré intégrer toutes les offres de jobs
qui était sur notre site s'appelle
jambes en stock tout ça va être
regroupés pour être plus lisible et plus
efficace et redévelopper et puis on fera
une action dont on reparlera en temps et
en heure autour de l'euro 2016 puisqu'on
va accueillir la france accueillir
l'euro 2016 et contre angers exactement
on me répondre à un appel à projet
régional pour développer des actions à
destination des jeunes à l'occasion de
l'euro merci beaucoup pierre yves stucki
je le rappelle yves une information
jeunesse ouvrira donc ses portes le 11
janvier à cette adresse le 3 parvis des
sources à montigny le bretonneux le site
internet s'affiche en bas de votre écran
vous pouvez y trouver toutes les
informations
et l'année 2015 vient de s'achever 2015
une année difficile pour les français
elle a notamment été marquée par les
tragiques attentats du 7 janvier et du
13 novembre dernier à paris politiques
société culture le département des
yvelines a également connu son lot
d'événements
retour sur cette année 2015 en quelques
minutes une année 2015 qui a débuté dans
la douleur le 7 janvier
les locaux du journal charlie hebdo sont
la cible d'une attaque terroriste
onze personnes sont assassinées par les
frères kwasi dont huit membres de la
rédaction
deux jours plus tard une nouvelle
attaque secoue la france amedi coulibaly
prend en otage les clients d'une
supérette cacher dans le 12e
arrondissement toujours à paris il tuera
quatre personnes avant d'être abattu par
les forces de police
en france l'émotion est vive et les
hommages se multiplient également dans
les yvelines
je suis touchée je pense que c'est des
événements qui sont intolérables et je
pense que face à ça on n'a pas le choix
que de se mobiliser
donc il faut absolument absolument faire
face faire face et est tous ensemble sur
des événements comme ça pour montrer que
quoi qu'il arrive enfin les français
sont des gens de liberté et qu'on n'est
pas prêt à aller à céder à ses libertés
aujourd'hui il faut absolument appeler
au rassemblement a appelé justement à ne
pas stigmatiser à ne pas diviser la
république elle est une elle est
indivisible et elle est unie dans
l'ensemble de sa diversité et c'est ça
qui fait la france et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui voilà ce rassemblement
est essentielle après l'émotion les
mesures de sécurité sont accrus le plan
vigipirate alerte attentat est activé
sur toute la france dès à présent les
sites sensibles sont protégés par les
militaires en bonne articulation avec
les forces de police et les forces de
gendarmerie pour assurer la sécurité
notre pays face aux menaces qui sont
maintenus c'est dans ce contexte que se
déroulent les élections départementales
si le premier tour en mars a peu
mobilisé il a révélé l'importance
grandissante du parti du front national
la droite déferle sur les yvelines lors
du second tour
les cantons de montigny le bretonneux et
de trappes historiquement à gauche
bascule premièrement c'est pas un coup
d'état ccc ce cd vote c'est un vote
démocratique d'abord bon les français
l'ont fallait les lillois l'ont voulu un
même moi j'ai été étonné parce que j'ai
vu les scores
moi j'ai vu dans des bureaux ici j'ai
fait 70% je n'ai jamais fait son
dimension d'un bureau de vote dans la
vie m'a donc on sent bien quand même
qu'il ya un rejet comme du socialisme
sans surprise les 42 conseillers
départementaux de droite et du centre
conduisent pierre bédier pour un nouveau
mandat à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
élargissement de la communauté
d'agglomération est au coeur des
discussions
cinq communes plaisir les
clayes-sous-bois villepreux coignières
et maurepas devrait rejoindre au 1er
janvier
les sept villes déjà associés doivent
alors se mettent autour d'une table
travaillez bien sûr sur l'intégration de
ces communes
parce que celles qui vont arriver
devront se mettre au niveau des communes
et qui existe déjà sur notre territoire
en sport l'événement phare pour 51 en
yvelines début 2015 c'est bien
évidemment les championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste
il se déroule au vélodrome nationale une
compétition où les français brillent
cinq titres et sept podiums sur 19 avec
deux titres supplémentaires a ajouté à
son palmarès
françois pervis et la star française de
ces mondiaux en fait un très bon
championnat du monde
on a montré qu'on savait pas le jour j
pour les jeux olympiques on a vraiment
pas peur sport toujours l'autrichien
berne vis derrière remporte la 99e
édition de l'open de france au golf
national de saint quentin en mai ce sont
les trappistes qui sont touchés par un
tragique événement
la mort du jeune moussa 14 ans tué d'une
rafale de pistolet mitrailleur dans les
secteurs des merisiers vivement qu'on
trouve qui a tué ce gosse on trouvera
parce que c'est pas possible de laisser
dans l'irresponsabilité l'assassinât
d'un gamin de 14 ans soit possible qui
nous guettait un gamin d'europe
de nombreux rassemblements ont lieu en
souvenir du jeune homme inquiète est
toujours en cours 1er septembre la
rentrée avec un nouveau préfet serge
morvan 56 ans chargé de la réforme
territoriale remplace erard corbin de
mangoux à la tête du département
un préfet très sollicité notamment par
l'arrivée des migrants syriens irakiens
la commune de bonnel dans les yvelines
est la première à les accueillir à saint
quentin en yvelines le mois d'octobre
est agitée pour l'agglomération entre
l'ancienne majorité est la nouvelle la
sphère des audi de la caisse qui posent
des questions sur les problèmes de
gestion
aujourd'hui les recrutements ils doivent
pas être partisan hallyday et doivent
être sur les compétences sur sur les
besoins de l'interco pas en fonction de
besoins de telle famille
de telles parties donc il faut remettre
quand même de l'éthique là en
l'occurrence l'impression qu'il ya
utilisation des moyens de
l'agglomération à des fins politiques au
profit d'une famille politique dans une
période électorale
au mois de novembre la france est à
nouveau frappé par un drame
le 13 novembre paris est victime de
plusieurs attaques terroristes
simultanée revendiqué par des shs les
10e 11e arrondissement le stade de
france et surtout la salle de spectacle
du bataclan sont visés le bilan est
tragique 130 morts et plus de 350
blessés
l'état d'urgence est prononcée en france
j'entends
comme des bruits de pétards en fait
et au départ je ne réalise pas vraiment
je tourne la tête à gauche je vois des
gens
tombée en fait comme des feuilles
et je réalise qu'ils ont quand même nom
ils nous ont blessés dans notre chère
mais nous tuerons pas sont prêts à
mourir en se faisant exploser
nous on est prêt à mourir revenant là où
on peut se faire exploser
on a on est pareil que à ce niveau là et
ça marchera pas parce que si on a peur
de la mort comme eux ils n'ont pas peur
aux mais perdant dans les yvelines comme
partout dans le monde de nombreuses
commémorations ont lieu cet attentat est
le plus dramatique que la france ait
connu des attentats que l'on retrouve au
coeur des élections régionales
l'événement politique de cette fin
d'année 2015 valérie pécresse remporte
la région ile de france le 13 décembre
elle était depuis 17 ans ou moins de la
gauche claude bartolone avait été
privilégié aux dépens de jean paul
huchon chère france yen cher franchir
j'aime notre région mais je sais que
vous attendez désormais non pas des
déclarations d'amour et des preuves
d'amour et hier nous vous avions demandé
vos voeux pour 2016 aujourd'hui il est
temps de penser aux bonnes résolutions
pour la nouvelle année
alors quelle est la vôtre c'est la
question que nous avons posée à regarder
je vais penser à moi cette année parce
que j'ai une année 2015 très difficile
donc j'espère que 2016 sera très bien
pour tout le monde
avoir du bois une conversation avec tout
le monde rigolait avec tout le monde
profite de la vie voilà de la joie que
je partage avec les français si en
france - et bien cette année j'en ai
plus aucune parce que chacun des champs
prenez puis je tenais aucune résolution
donc je me suis dit c'est plus simple
cette année je n'en prends pas ne pas en
rester au lit trop longtemps et se
coucher à des heures comment ne pas
s'abriter derrière la télévision être
raisonnable savoir gré ils ont gardé
être modérée la modération au tout
conduit à la sagesse et on espère que
vous allez les tenir c'est la fin de
cette édition je vous remercie de nous
avoir suivis je vous retrouve demain
pour une nouvelle édition du journal je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée